-In the clip we showed whe
we first had you come out,
your brother is in there.
Your brother is one of
the co-stars in that film.
-Yes. Yes, my brother Paul
The David Lee Roth of the group.
-Right.
-As we've mentioned.
Yes, yeah, Paul got to be in it.
And he plays -- he plays -
he plays Carl Glatzel.
-Have you guys ever been
in a film before?
-We actually did do one othe
movie together
called "Big Stone Gap."
But this was a great deal
for him to be in the movie
And he auditioned
totally on his own.
I had nothing to do
with his audition.
You know,
once it got to a point,
I was like, "That's my brother!"
[ Laughter ]
And then --
yeah, it was awesome.
I mean, you know, as you know,
regardless of how a movie does
your movie is defined
by the experience you have
-Yeah.
-So for me, I had this house
down in Atlanta when we shot it.
And having him there
for a couple months,
we hadn't lived together,
you know, since we were kids
So, it was awesome.
-Now, a lot of times,
these horror movies
are all special effects
and they're not particularly
scary onset.
-Yeah, this is true.
-But you know, this was
from the second film
where you had a wonderful,
this is a genuine --
this is a person.
-Yeah, Javier. Yeah.
-Obviously in make up.
But this seemed like it woul
actually be terrifying
in real time.
-And I've done a few of them
Of all the horror movies
that I've done,
working with Javier
on that scene in particular,
we finished the take and I said,
"That's the scariest thing
that I've ever done."
Because usually again,
it's all done technically.
-Yeah, but --
-But the way that he --
but the way that he can move
and he shot this whole sequenc
backwards.
This is a true story.
And he shot it backwards
and then we played it forwards
But it looks like it's don
digitally and it's just not.
It probably wasn't as scar
to the audience as it was to m
being in the room watching it.
Terrifying, totally terrifying
-It does strike me
that your kids are the age
where they might want to engag
in horror movies like this
-Yeah.
-Have they seen these films?
Do they like them?
-They have. They have.
They love them.
And I feel like
a terrible parent
every time they watch them
Because my 11-year-old
who loves it,
who's fascinated by it,
you know.
But we're always like, God
please don't wake up
and have a nightmare
'cause then I'm just going t
feel like the worst.
-It seems like that's
technically the age where it
would be okay to watch a movie
like that.
-It gets there.
It gets there.
I mean, he's also --
They're also, you know,
they've grown up on sets,
so they'll still -- they'r
demystified in one sense
because they see it
all happening.
But yet when
it's still put together,
for them, there's still that
wonderful child imagination.
-Alright, is there
stuff that you've done
that they're just
flat out bored?
And, if so, do they ever
tell you? Or are they good
Are they good kids,
that they're like,
"That was another A-plus, Dad.
-No, yeah,
I don't know if I get that
I mean, they're still teenagers.
-Right.
-Like, "No, it's good, Dad
it's really good."
Yeah.
No, they're super supportive
They love coming
to all the sets.
-Was like "Aquaman" for them
a fun set to be on?
I would imagine.
-"Aquaman" was cool becaus
we shot the first one
in Australia.
So for them, it was --
-Right.
-But when you talk about
"Aquaman" in Australia,
they're not talking
about going to set.
They're talking about the beac
and everything else.
So, it's like --
"Yeah, Dad's at work."
You're inside all day.
It's in a stage.
-When you went to --
you mentioned that you wen
and saw the screening
of the new movie.
-Yeah.
-Were people aware
that you were there?
-No.
No, we totally surprised them.
-Oh, but then did you reveal
-Yes.
-Gotcha.
-Ta-da!
Thank God, cause my fear
was like I'd go, "Hey!"
And they'd go, "Who are you?
Be the worst.
-You wait until the end
of the movie.
-So terrible.
No, but you know,
it was awesome.
Because that was
the opening night,
and of course, I said,
"I want to see a show of hands
how many people have seen
all seven films,"
this being the seventh.
And so many hands went up.
But what was cool,
is I swear to you,
about 80% of that audience
it was their first time in
a theater since the pandemic
So to me, yes,
I want you to see the movie,
but just to see how people
are coming back
to the movies was such
a huge, huge deal for me.
-Because it's also,
you can see it --
-Yeah, you can see it
at home on HBO Max.
-So that really I think speaks
to the value
of that collective experienc
of going to the movies.
-Yeah, it does.
It really does.
I mean, right now we can see o
it any format that works for us.
But, you know, there's nothing
like going to the movies.
-Yeah. Well, thanks, man,
for making the time
and being here in person.
Really appreciate it.
Congrats on the film.
-Thanks, buddy.
-"The Conjuring:
The Devil Made Me Do It"
is in theatres
and on HBO Max now.